[Music]
dear zoe
i have memories of you from before you
were even born
here we are again just friends in the
dark question
[Music]
hey em
can i see
what is it
santa lying face down crying
cause something has changed
this has nothing to do with zoey
everything else does
what's going on
is your mom okay
can i come in
i'm really glad you're here
yeah me too
why is she here ellie's the custodial
parent not you huh not you
i know you've been through hell
but i know that that kid in there
is obviously hurting too
[Music]
i'm your big sister i was supposed to
protect you
are you coming back home i need some
time i just i have to clear my head
[Music]
you're insane this is insane if my dad
finds out
i know that guy
[Music]
gotta get my act together focus on being
a parent
can i kiss you a good night
yes
is it cool if this one knocks off early
i love you
i love you too
let's fly
your mom and me
we managed to do one thing right
you were funny and loud
and sweet
and i will never
ever forget you
love always
tests
[Music]
they teach me how to drive oh
that's a scary word
it's right up there with uh
where do babies come from
[Music]